- I know tens of
thousands of people,
and I know thousands
of people extremely well,
and I know hundreds
of people deeply well.
There is no correlation
between how much money
someone makes and
their level of happiness.
I have friends who
make $47,000 a year,
and they're the
happiest people I know.
Their work-life
balance is on point,
they're part of
two soccer teams,
they play video games,
they watch every show they want,
they take two vacations
that they scrap together,
and they're
freaking happy as well.
And I know tons of
people who I grew up with
in the Silicon Valley
boom who have hundreds
of millions of dollars
in their bank account
and are as
miserable and as lonely
and as broken
as you'll ever see,
so I implore all of you
to please reverse engineer
and figure out who you are,
and figure out what level of
monetizing and stuff you need,
and what level of
creativity you need.
I promise you one thing,
one thing that will
catch you very off-guard.
I should be way more rich.
I leave money on
the table every day.
I've left ungodly amounts
of money on the table.
I spend tons of time sending DMs
and engaging with people
and meeting people randomly
and not cashing in.
I actually believe the
statement I'm about to make.
I think that I love
the journey and the game
of entrepreneurship so much
that I have subconsciously
sabotaged my financial upside
to make sure I can
play this a little longer,
'cause I fear if the
numbers keep getting too big,
eventually, it will
take the fun out of it.
When you are
lucky enough like I am
to actually do something
that you love so much,
do something that puts
pressure against the one thing
you care about besides it,
which is the time
I spend with my family.
My family's my whole life,
and being this and doing this
is the only thing
that cuts into that.
I couldn't breathe if
I wasn't an entrepreneur.
I didn't breathe when
That's the reason I got
D's and F's in school.
'Cause I just couldn't be me,
and I'm not capable of that.
And so, I think
being here excites me
because I think coming
to not L.A., San Francisco,
New York, London, is
always more fun for me.
It always feels a
little more practical.
It always feels like
there's a little bit more
chips on the shoulder,
which is what I have.
But I wanna remind everybody,
just 'cause you didn't
grow up with a trust fund,
just 'cause you don't
live in Silicon Valley,
the market doesn't care.
If you're good
enough, you will win,
(light hip hop beat)